[Musique]
bah ouais c'est sûr je me mets à béziers
mais après on ne sait pas forcément ce
que je suis j'aime bien dessiner en tout
cas ça c'est sûr après j'ai pas beaucoup
le temps de lire mais c'est clair que ça
fait toujours plaisir de lire une bd
quoi bon en fait il m'a planches c'est
l'histoire de deux chiens est en fait
les deux chiens cd chien en peluche que
j'avais moins et mon frère quand on
était petit et du coup pas forcément ça
m'inspire et j'en avais déjà fait plein
d'histoires ensemble et donc c'était
assez facile de trouver une histoire
avec ces deux personnages
moi j'ai fait le tour avant j'ai
remarqué beaucoup de références aux
films de cow-boys ou des films
fantastiques ou même il s'inspire aussi
de d'autres bd et de mangas aussi par
exemple on en voit beaucoup les jeunes
disent beaucoup de mangas en ce moment
et des comics aussi pour les super héros
et c'est vrai qu'on trouve des codes des
références basse et d'autres héros mais
voilà il s'en inspire mais il montre pas
que
il montre pas que c'est ce à quoi ils
sans l'inscrire simplement quoi